[MUSIC PLAYING]
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: AT here.
I'm a program manager on the
Google for Education Team.
You may have seen me on
the EDU in 90 series.
HEATHER CROSS: So glad
you could join us, AT.
So in today's
episode, we're going
to talk about a critical part
of any business, protection
and management of data.
And mismanagement of
sensitive information
can come at all costs.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS:
The challenge is
how to protect sensitive
data while still being
able to use it for important
business functions,
like running analytics or
customer support operations.
HEATHER CROSS: Well, we've got
an answer for this, Cloud Data
Loss Prevention API.
We'll also run through a quick
demo of the self-paced lab
where we'll set up
a DLP API and use
it to inspect a string of data
for sensitive information.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: So when it
comes to properly handling
sensitive data, the first step
is knowing where it exists.
Well, the DLP API uses
a variety of techniques
to identify sensitive
data like credit card
numbers, social
security numbers, names,
and other forms of personally
identifiable information.
In addition to identifying
sensitive data within text
content, the API can detect
and classify sensitive data
within standard
bitmap images too.
HEATHER CROSS: Applying
the API to tech streams
allows you to
automatically redact
or censor any sensitive data
before it writes to disk,
generates logs, or is used
to perform analysis tasks.
Identifying sensitive
data upfront
also allows you to choose the
most suitable storage system
and appropriate access
controls for that data.
The DLP API classifies
raw data by using
a set of predefined detectors
to identify patterns, formats,
and checksums.
The API can even understand
contextual clues.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: Once you
know where your sensitive data
lives, the API gives you the
option to deidentify that data.
So what does that mean?
Deidentifying data removes
identifying information
from a dataset, making it
more difficult to associate
the remaining data
with an individual
and reducing the
risk of exposure.
The resulting data is then
suitable for apps, storage,
or analysis.
HEATHER CROSS: Redaction removes
entire values or entire records
from a dataset.
Partial masking hides
parts of the data,
leaving some data visible--
for example, the
last seven digits
of a US telephone number.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: Tokenization,
or secure hashing,
replaces sensitive
data with a key.
This is often used in
credit card processing.
Dynamic data masking applies
deidentification and masking
techniques in real time.
This can be useful if you don't
want to alter your underlying
data but want to mask it
when viewed by certain users.
Special access
privileges could be
applied for those
who need to view it,
say HR or a finance team.
HEATHER CROSS: The DLP
API integrates with many
of our other GCP services too.
Cloud Functions can
help you automate
the classification
of data that's
uploaded to Cloud Storage.
Also, there's a built-in support
for scanning and classifying
sensitive data and Cloud
Storage, Cloud Datastore,
and BigQuery.
Cloud Pub/Sub notifications
can be generated in response
to a completed inspection jobs.
We then created
a service account
to access the Google Cloud
APIs when testing locally
and gave the service account
the required permissions.
We then generated a
service account key.
So first, we create a JSON file
with sensitive information.
In this case, it's
a phone number.
We authenticate to
our service account,
passing the location of the
service account key file,
and obtain an
authorization token
using the service account.
We can then use the curl
command to inspect the JSON
file for sensitive information.
And the response shows that
the phone number was found
with a likelihood of likely.
We can also redact
sensitive information.
We create a second
JSON file, this time
with a sensitive email address.
We can then use the curl
command to deidentify the JSON
file for sensitive information.
We can see the
response that the email
address has been replaced.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: Well, that's
the end of another episode.
We hope you enjoyed it.
If you've got some
great examples
of how you've been
able to apply this API,
please share it with us.
HEATHER CROSS: And
make sure to check out
the link where you can apply
what you've learned today
and use a $300 free trial credit
at Google Cloud platform here.
A.T. MCWILLIAMS: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks for watching.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]